[Music]
get in fit gettin healthy waiting for
some cats to join the feed but meantime
man let's check in on the Shecky action
don't hold on look at that man
yes nature in action ladies and
gentlemen that's right man that's what
we come out here to do take a whiz and
move the [ __ ] on man cuz a Shakey's
world look at how happy this dog is you
wouldn't believe that this dog was 14
years old
she's so plucky look at her like a like
a just the happiest turd she's like a
little the little [ __ ] emoji come to
life but just vibrant all right back to
it never mind her alright man so it's
been a minute since I've hiked Runyon
heading to Runyon where am I look at
this shirt my Hot Topic Brotherhood weed
dealer shirt sound Bob urgent available
at hot topic right now because this
weekend we just got finished with San
Diego Comic Con oh good lord
J is it you know what it's not bright
enough for this [ __ ]
here we go Jay and Silent Bob reboot got
introduced to the world I'm very
familiar with the movie haven't been
working on it for well a better part of
two and a half years and even further
back if you go to when I truck was
trying to make clerks three and Mallrats
two pieces of which wound up in Jay and
Silent Bob rebooted talking if I can
walk in not my thing
I like sitting and talking so finally
this weekend we well Thursday
we launched the trailer if you have not
seen it go to reboot Roadshow dot-com
check out the trailer maybe pick up
tickets to see us at the live show some
people are asking like I don't get it
it's getting a wide release or not now
the kind of wide release like 2,000
screens at once we don't have that kind
of picture we're that kind of money so
we're doing you know working smarter not
harder kind of thing first off for
everyone that wants to see see it
immediately there'll be a sneak to sneak
preview screenings through fathom on
October 15th and 17th so you can watch
the movie there'll be stuff for me and J
intros second night and they're doing
strike back and reboot back-to-back
which I'm actually going for man I'm me
and J have been threatening to do that
to watch strike back and reboot back to
back for the last month so maybe we'll
do it at the fat in the vent then me and
J go on tour
reboot Roadshow right now there's like
30 dates up more dates coming we're
adding them we just kind of wanted to
launch with as many dates as we had
locked but there's lots of dates we were
negotiating for other places like New
Jersey everyone's like why the [ __ ] are
you coming no Josh hey Chris I'm going
back to the motherland son Canada will
be added to that as well
but all that stuff's forthcoming then
when the say we go to like we open the
tour in Chicago we go to the Chicago
biggest music box theater where I don't
know I forget where we were going sorry
my bad
but once the show is done there say we
go on a Wednesday or something on Friday
then the movie opens at that Newton a
theater near you so we're platforming it
kind of mixture platform and and this
touring thing which works very well for
us
so check out reboot roadshow come from
work that brought me back to my shirt so
Hot Topic doing a lot of shirts
and all of them each one cooler than the
next I love merchandise kids I've been
doing merchandise since 1995 when we
opened up USQ comm and one day my idea I
came he said I was clever enough to come
up with when we opened up the website
people were like what are you selling
and I was like I guess the idea of these
movies and then there's a no don't you
have merch and I said what do you mean
like don't you have posters don't you
have anything to sell and I said I guess
we do we have a bunch of Mallrats
posters in the closet that I thought I'd
be buried with one day start signing
them selling then we start making
t-shirts of our own and stuff so I
always liked making stuff I mean yeah
there's don't get me wrong there's like
money to be made but I grew up buying
other people's stuff George Lucas made
Kenner deals made action figures Star
Wars sheets t-shirts and stuff Batman
Snoopy Six Million Dollar Man only makes
sense that I grew up and even with my
limited IP with limited IQ that I too
was like oh that's self [ __ ] but it
ain't ever for really for the money it's
more the thrill of like walking around
seeing somebody wearing your [ __ ] on
their chest pretty dope okay we're not
even at Runyon I'm [ __ ] winded this
is the walk to Runyon and it takes a
bunch out of me man schecky doing just
fine but days overcast so that's pretty
sweet
hey normally what happens it's pretty
hot and he's [ __ ] July it drizzled
this morning normally it's like blazing
here by this time and then the dog just
gives up halfway through and then I got
a carrier up the hill we just defeats
the point of the walk
temperatures right though so I think
shaking might make it all the way um
this is the place where well don't get
all hostile she sees another dog she's
just like lunges this is a place where
signal might start crapping out which is
probably for the best otherwise you're
gonna see me at death's door oh um
there's uh jump she's like - hi come on
don't get gather store um who is dog
heaven kids unless you got a dog
yourself who wants to fight every dog in
the world um also intimidation heaven
cuz every dude coming down the hill
we're gonna up the hill unlike me is not
wearing t-shirts
generally speaking shirtless and I'm not
saying there's a expectation that I too
should be shirtless but others passing
go like well that was a man and he had
his shirt off are you a man I'm like no
not at all not even if the worst part
yeah worst part is where start gasping
for air that's where this will go quiet
for everybody who's ever been like I
wish Kevin Smith to shut the [ __ ] up
you're gonna see it as soon as we get up
climb up Runyon way Oh Lord meanwhile I
was checking on shaggy
okay all right climb begins if I go away
this walk and my subsequent death in the
middle of said walk sponsored by Hot
Topic where they're gonna be selling
sweet shirts like that like the one I'm
wearing as I try to pretend that I'm not
48 and climb up what I call a mountain
they call a hill when I first moved out
here to see Runyon Canyon from our house
don't try to fight with every [ __ ]
dog you see how's that bites for
everybody I said oh my god we live next
to a mountain and I was told and a
mountain sound that's a hill that's the
Hollywood Hills we don't have like a
mountain range in New Jersey says
closest I ever lived to a man all right
we're almost up to him to Hersh it's
gonna get real and when I mean real I
mean real [ __ ] bad but again dog
heaven and if I was unscrupulous that
turned my video on all the dogs that
Chucky tries to attack if you're into
that dog attack porn no no no I have to
keep her on a short leash mostly
everyone else takes their dogs off the
leash you're on run oh my god in my wake
you see an army of dogs can I can I
shoot your dogs not shoot them to film
them oh you gotta see this
look at that that's just majestic look
at the control how do you do it it's
amazing look at them all I can't do one
well done ma'am you have my my respect
thank you
that's the kind of [ __ ] you seek no no
no don't stop that's kind of [ __ ] you
see of it Runyan a veritable dog parade
um how's she doing
how do I can't wrangle this one little
wiener she's got like 96 dogs it's
amazing
all right the journey begins the journey
of a million miles kids they say begins
with a single step
that's [ __ ]
it begins with a willingness to take the
single step and that's the toughest
thing in the world to muster let's start
or let's start again so here we are
starting again look at the gorgeous
here's California in the background Los
Angeles saw the hills majestic healthy
people I'm not one of them
check these hills morning some people
can do it backwards I cannot I barely do
it forward
Sega you barely do it all but you know
what 14 times 7-eleven 200 I don't know
can't do the math barely any oxygen whoo
I told you I go silent there's moments
like this I'm reminded how much I smoke
my cigarette a weed smoke caviar gold
right before I went on this Trek
beautiful sativa that was pumped full
CBDs that was made just for me but you
get caviar a lot of weed shots but I
spoke this thing and I was ready son
he's cuz clean crisp eye so I'm like
let's go up hiking so this is me baked
but as you can see I'm passing nobody
recognizes I'm in an amazing place in my
head and heart and soul after killer
morning smoke wake and bake and a great
weekend comic-con if you didn't get a
chance check out all the video we shot
on the IMD boat with a bunch of folks
who came out talk about their stuff
their movies and TV shot oh man just
went the stick didn't realize it was
always gonna summer his adorable
stop trying fight with every way she
sees the dog she goes after the dog and
then Hall H was phenomenal we showed the
trailer and then we also showed a big
part of the Brody scene cell which is
played through the roof but did better
at in that room Comic Con where's
Brody's one of them it's that plane
scene play great then also we did the
blonde cave sequence so they got to see
Melissa and Val and Tommy it was great
had a great time I was worried as per
usual nobody would be there especially
following in the Marvel panel which was
huge and let's talk about one movie they
were like here's the next 20 years your
life which is really only two so we had
about five thousand a 65 men right not
bad not bad considering not Marvel and
yet still for our went out on stage I
was like terrified it's like oh my god
why do I do this to myself what if
nobody's here I don't have to do this
why do I tie my self-worth up to this he
going it's on fight dogs and had a
little breakdown it's a Melissa Melissa
Benoist was with us backstage like she
later on she's like your eyes were so
wide so I was like I'm scared scared of
failing everybody is I spent so much
time telling people that
felling is not trying so but I measure
why the hell am I scared often it's
easier to tell people what to do than to
do it yourself
alright we're stopping for the water
we're at the water break let's watch
Chucky in action
all right back out at this ain't even
the top but let's take a look at that
view
we're like the midway point this bench
here I remember when I first moved to
California Larry I was working out with
this guy Larry he's a trainer from South
Africa I did the accent instead so
anyway he was like he'll go to Runyon
and we went up made it to that bench and
I was like I can't do it bro can't this
as high as I go now I go all the way up
how was years ago I was like 2002
so 17 years ago that was the end of
Runyon for me 17 years later we're gonna
keep going kids we're gonna go until we
lose signal and then I'm gonna keep
going regardless chainsaw Bob reboot
ladies gentlemen it's coming October
lots of merch coming your way I'm
wearing some now Funko pops action
figures from Diamond Select his all the
fun stuff the ephemera that goes along
with making a movie huh let's see I got
a big meeting today
there's a lot of that you get a lot of
people going oh ho because it cuz the
Wiener big meeting today writers meeting
for this thing have it talking about me
and Mark Barnard working um then we have
a QC screening of Jay and Sam Bob reboot
the final screening of Sayers no no no
no fiber duck final screening to say
like this is that it's locked and we're
done forever and then I go to premiere
tonight I get to go see one spot somehow
because my kids in it so that's gonna be
a blast I get to geek out another
filmmaker with other filmmakers work
like this cuz my kids inner I get to go
to the premiere this kids finally paying
off after all the money I put into this
kid alright now we're gonna go for the
signals getting weak something let y'all
go before I lose you thanks for hanging
out for me and Shaggy one last legs
check later what a champ the brown
bullet firing up the hill
[Music]
you
you